now everything's black and white and you
really have to be comfortable with that
gray area and that ambiguity working for
something that's already created is way
different than creating something
yourself if you're an entrepreneur
there's no path that's laid out for you
so you have to be comfortable walking
into that darkness and knowing that
you're gonna come out on the other side
Ryan I started APL on the foundation
that we created the world's best
basketball technology the concept of
being the first to do something for me
is really exciting so he created the
first technology the instant makes you
jump higher October 19 2010 our shoes
got banned by the NBA and we said you
can either fight this or we can embrace
this let's keep going with this and see
how far we can take it it was the best
thing that ever happened for us this one
moment changed the trajectory of our
lives if you see a great opportunity and
you feel that you can personally
maximize it you need to take because you
never know when the next one's coming
from an innovation standpoint we're able
to look at something from a different
angle Nordstrom was the first account
really opened up that has over 100
stores and is at pretty much every state
we expect a lot of the people to work
for us but at the same time we want it
to be more than just work you want to be
fun as well whether it's pink darts on
the mini basketball hoop ping-pong we
have a creative environment in office
the only way to get furthers that get
out of your comfort zone it's consistent
hard work every single day Adam and I
are usually up until about 3 or 4 a.m.
every day we're dealing with all
different places from London to Paris to
New York a lot of the huge opportunities
that we
have come from saying why not us